PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
The title of our talk
is Instant Buy Everywhere,
How to Turbocharge Mobile
Monetization, and so how you
can score more goals when
it comes to
monetizing your apps.
So I'm Prakash Hariramani.
I'm Product Manager of
the Google Wallet team.
And with me is--
MICHAEL GALPIN:
I'm Michael Galpin.
I'm the engineer
on the Wallet team.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
And today we're
going to talk
about a few things.
But before we talk
about the details,
I just want to mention that we
were here last year standing
in front of you when we launched
this product called Instant
Buy.
We've come a long
way since then.
And a lot of it is thanks to
you all and your enthusiasm.
So the three themes we have for
today are platform expansion.
So Instant Buy today is now
on all major mobile commerce
platforms.
What I mean by that is Android,
iOS, mobile web, and desktop.
Instant Buy everywhere.
The second theme is
developer expansion.
So we're really gratified.
We'll talk about some
of the case studies
and the developer
interest we generated,
and the number of developers who
are live, and more importantly,
growing benefits
on the platform.
And then the last thing
we're going to talk about
is a little bit beyond payments.
Because to us, commerce
is not just payments.
It's about the whole
shopping experience.
So I use my Android phone
for my entire journey
when I'm shopping.
It's not just when I'm
making the payment,
but right from the time I'm
searching for something,
when I want to have
my loyalty or offer
information be part
of that journey.
So we'll talk about that, too.
So first let's
talk about mobile.
So we are living in
a mobile-first world.
And this is a
mobile-first product.
So I'm sure you've seen
similar charts like this.
Mobile commerce is
something that's
growing extremely rapidly.
As you can see in this
chart, one of every five
transactions-- roughly
20% of all transactions
are on mobile devices.
Mobile commerce volume is
supposed to be 84 billion
in 2014.
And if you take
a step back, it's
amazing that 20% of all
transactions that are online
will be mobile.
That's almost double what
it was two years ago.
So that was the good news.
So what's the bad news?
Or what's the sobering news?
The sobering news is a typical
mobile checkout still takes
about 24 steps.
I'd like to have
a show of hands.
How many of you
have tried to make
a purchase on a mobile device--
let's say, buying a ticket,
or take out-- and have had
to abandon it midstream?
OK.
Well, there is hope.
We'll talk about how we
can solve that pain point.
So why is it so difficult to buy
something from a mobile device?
Why 24 steps?
So let's take a
typical check out flow.
What happens?
You select what you want.
You put it into your cart.
You confirm your order.
And then the pain starts.
So at a high level, the pain
points are in two broad areas.
One area is entering your
credit card information,
your expiration date,
your billing address.
And God forbid if
your shipping address
differs from your
billing address.
The second pain point is
registration and signing up.
So together, when you put
these pain points together,
no wonder there's a
problem with conversion.
99% of mobile shoppers
abandon a purchase mid-flow.
Now I started the theme
saying turbocharging
mobile monetization.
And to get mobile
monetization, you
need to have high conversion.
To have high conversion, you
need to have less friction.
And what we just talked about
is actually adding friction.
So how do we solve this?
This is staggering.
You, as developers, are losing
money because of high friction.
So how do we solve this
problem for monetization?
So we'd like to offer a
solution, Google Wallet Instant
Buy.
And I want to walk
through how we
believe we have
solved this problem.
So the first thing we
have done is faster
checkout for physical goods.
I'd like to have a
show of hands again.
How many of you have made
a purchase on any Google
property, like Google Play, or
Drive, or anything like a game,
or a book, or
something on Google?
OK.
Well, the good news is you
all have a Google Wallet.
And the better news is you can
use that Google Wallet to make
purchases not just on Play
and Google properties,
but also on
third-party merchants--
the ones that have
integrated with Instant Buy.
So speed is everything
in mobile commerce.
And remember I said earlier
there's two big pain points.
One is a pain point of entering
credit card information.
Well, by virtue of you
having a Google Wallet,
by virtue of having made a
purchase on a Google property,
you've eliminated
that pain point.
So it's really two taps,
two clicks, and check out.
The second pain
point I talked about
was skipping
registration and sign-in.
So don't make your customers
fill out these registration
forms with special character
passwords and caps and all
the other hoops.
If you integrate with
Google Single Sign-On,
essentially, you can
eliminate that one step.
Anyone who has a
Google identity,
by virtue of having set up a
Gmail account or having used
another Google service, can
enter those credentials.
And I'm going to talk about
this also in our case studies
because developers like
yourself, who have integrated
both Single Sign-On
and Instant Buy,
have found higher conversion.
So let's talk about
security because what
I talked about earlier
was the convenience.
Traditionally,
convenience and security
has been a zero sum game,
if you can have something
very convenient at the expense
of security or vice versa.
We believe that's
a false choice.
And we believe we have
raised the bar on both.
So with convenience,
like I said earlier,
if you use Single Sign-On--
and actually if you're
on an Android
device, you're always
logged in-- we believe we have
solved that friction problem.
So what are we doing
about security?
How do we make sure
the transaction's
secure both for you, as
a developer or merchant,
and for the end user,
which is your customer?
Well, one is we generate
a one-time virtual card
for every transaction.
It's like a one-time
Discover card.
So it's unique for
that transaction,
and that protects your user.
The other thing we do is we
have a very sophisticated risk
engine.
So if we suspect fraud, we
will challenge the user, and in
some cases, deny
the transaction.
And that protects
you as a developer.
The next question that always
comes up is integration.
How easy or difficult
is this to integrate?
So the good news is
it's only one or two
weeks of integration.
And Michael's going to talk
about something we just
recently released in the
last few months, which
is called Wallet Fragment.
So that's made the integration
process even easier.
But there's one other important
point with integration.
We do not get in the middle
of your payment processor
or acquirer.
So when we generate this
one-time Discover card,
it can ride the rails of
your existing processor.
So if you're using a
Stripe or a Paymentech,
you don't need to
make any changes.
You can just continue using
that payment processing.
Now that helps in many ways.
One is many of our merchants
and developers have said,
I want to keep that
existing relationship.
The second way it helps is
by minimizing the integration
burden, because you
don't have to change
any of your
downstream processing.
And the other thing I'll add
is, don't take my word for it.
We have a partner showcase.
We have three or four partners
there that you will see,
Eat24, JackThreads,
and Hotel Tonight.
So I'd encourage you to go
there and ask them firsthand
about the integration
experience.
So finally, what's the catch?
This sounds good.
Well, there is no catch.
There are no additional fees.
We don't charge
anything for using
Google Wallet Instant Buy.
Like I said earlier, you will
need a payment processor,
so you'll continue
paying those fees.
So in summary, I
think we have talked
about how we can
remove the pain points.
Paint point of entering
your payment information.
Pain point of registration
and signing up.
How it's secure and convenient.
And we raised the bar on both.
Lightweight integration.
And no additional fees.
So before we talk about
where we want to go, let's
talk about where we have been.
So like I said at the
beginning of the talk,
it's been about a year since we
launched Instant Buy on Android
and Michael and I
stood in front of you.
We made you some promises.
So we actually have been
able to fulfill the promises.
And when we talk
about case studies,
I'll elaborate on those.
So May was our launch
on Android at I/O.
This was a limited launch.
We had about a dozen or so
developers we announced.
The next milestone
we hit was October.
So we opened up sandbox
access to everyone.
In fact, I would encourage any
of you who have a mobile app
or site that accepts
payments, I would
encourage you to
go to our sandbox,
go to our developer site,
and kick the tires with it.
The next milestone
we had was this year.
And we launched two things.
One is Wallet Fragment,
which I talked about.
And Michael will do more
justice to this than me.
The other thing
is Wallet Balance.
So I use my Google Wallet a
lot for sending and receiving
money.
Now I can use that same
balance for making a purchase
on an Instant Buy merchant.
And Michael's going
to actually do
a demonstration on that, too.
And then, just hot off
the press, earlier in June
we launched on iOS.
So now we, again, continuing
the theme of Instant
Buy everywhere, we
are now supported
on all major mCommerce
platforms, including iOS.
MICHAEL GALPIN: Prakash,
this is Google I/O.
I don't think anybody
here is using iOS.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So on
that note, let's do a demo.
And I'm starving, Michael.
I didn't get a chance
to get breakfast.
I got so excited
about this talk,
so I thought let me
just order some food
while we're up on stage.
MICHAEL GALPIN: Sounds good.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So this
is one of my favorite apps.
It's Eat24.
And for those of you
who were here yesterday,
there was a demo of
Eat24 on Android Wear.
So besides that you can also
use it on an iOS device.
So let me try Pebbles Deli Cafe.
So I can order
something right now.
Well, iOS devices.
[LAUGHTER]
OK, let's give it one more shot.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Apparently,
you're getting started up.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So while
switching back, we'll be--
[LAUGHTER]
We'll come back to this.
But I would encourage you
to come to the Eat24 booth
and give a shot on
all major platforms.
MICHAEL GALPIN: The iOS gods
are getting their revenge now.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
So one thing I
said earlier was I was really
gratified that we have-- thanks
to you all, thanks to all
the developer support we got,
we've come a long
way since last year.
So this is the
representative sample
of all the different
verticals we are across.
As you can see, some
few highlights here.
Travel is one of the largest
verticals in mCommerce.
So we are really gratified.
We have almost all the
major travel companies here,
like Priceline, like Expedia,
like Orbitz, like Travelocity.
The other thing I want
to flag is Order Ahead.
So besides Eat24 we also
have Domino's Pizza.
We launched with them recently.
It's another one of my
favorite Order Ahead apps.
We have a lot of
traction in retail.
The other thing I
want to talk about
is we're really gratified
that many of these
are mobile-first companies.
So I said earlier, we are
a mobile-first product
in a mobile-first world.
And many of these companies are
not just integrating with us,
they are actually transforming
the whole customer experience.
So for example, Uber
pioneered rights sharing.
Eat24 transformed the
take out experience.
Airbnb transformed the
hotel and tourism industry.
Hotel Tonight has transformed
last minute bookings.
So we're really excited that
these companies have actually
made us part of their journey.
And when I say us, I don't
just mean Google Wallet Instant
Buy, but the entire
Google stack.
So what do I mean by that?
So if you look at our partner
showcase, with Hotel Tonight,
not only can you pay
conveniently in two clicks
with Google Wallet
Instant Buy, you
can have keyless entry
to your hotel room.
I hate standing in
a lobby when I'm
trying to check into a hotel.
I'd love to be able to
just go to my room door
and know where I'm checking in.
JackThreads.
Not only can I buy
something fashionable,
I can actually try it
on in a virtual Hangout
before I buy it.
And you can see this in action
today at the partner showcase.
MICHAEL GALPIN: And
you've got to check out
the Android TV app from Eat24.
I know Prakash will want to
maybe order that bagel there.
It's Android, so it'll work.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So
I can be hungry, lazy,
and stylish at the same time.
OK.
So let's talk a little
bit about case studies.
As I said earlier, we made
some promises last year
about this product.
So one of the promises
we made was conversion.
And the good news is
we've been able to deliver
on that promise.
And again, this goes
to attack the problem,
the 99% abandonment rate.
So Ruelala, as you
know, is a destination
for desired brands at
members only prices.
They were our launch
partner last year.
They saw a 400%
increase in conversion.
And they also saw 50%
more repeat purchases.
So again, talking
about monetization.
Continuing on that theme, Fancy.
They saw a 20%
increase in conversion.
And they also had a 14%
increase in average order size.
Priceline.
Again, like I
said, we are really
gratified we have all the major
online travel agencies that
have integrated
with Instant Buy.
And they saw a 71%
higher conversion rate.
And they also saw
a lot of traction
with the share of Google
Wallet transactions on Android.
And finally, Eat24.
So the common theme, as you
have noticed across these case
studies, is conversion.
So 70% increase in conversion.
One of every three purchases
on their Android devices
is a Google Wallet transaction.
And we have launched with
them for just about six months
or so.
And Google Wallet users are
72% more likely to return.
So again, going back
to turbocharging
mobile monetization, you
get higher conversion,
more repeat users, higher
average order size.
The other thing
I would recommend
is-- we have all these case
studies posted publicly.
I just gave you the headlines.
And this is all on
our website, so I
would encourage you to go
check it out for yourself.
And with that, I'm going to
transition it to Michael.
MICHAEL GALPIN: OK.
So as Prakash
mentioned, overstock.com
launched a new version
of their app recently
that integrates Google Wallet.
So now we're going to do
another demo-- hopefully,
this one goes a little
better-- to show you guys
what the Overstock
app looks like.
So could we-- OK.
So in the app there's
lots of awesome things
you can buy from Overstock.
I've picked out a
FIFA World Cup soccer
ball that looked pretty cool.
So I'm going to purchase it.
This is their cart page.
You'll notice the beautiful
Buy with Google button
down there at the bottom.
So of course, I'm
going to tap on that.
This brings up the
Wallet UI where
I can use whatever credit
card I want to use,
any credit card I've used
to buy anything from Google,
buy anything from
the Play Store.
Maybe I've got some Candy Crush
and app purchases I've made.
All those cards will be
available to me there.
And a shipping
address to ship to.
Of course, Overstock
requires a shipping address,
since they're going to send
me this great soccer ball.
And also notice that I
can use my Wallet balance
for this transaction.
I see I've got $21 in there.
That means Prakash must have
paid me for our World Cup bet.
I bet there'd be at
least one biting that
would happen during the event.
And Prakash paid me by Gmail.
So I've got some
extra cash in there.
So let's use that
for my purchase.
OK.
So now I just go to the
Overstock checkout page.
I see some of the
same information
here that I just
picked-- I'm using
Google Wallet, what
card I'm using.
And I'm using my
Wallet balance as well.
I see my shipping address here.
So I can look over this,
make sure it looks good.
If I want to change it, I
just tap on the Change button.
But everything looks
good here, so I'm just
going to go ahead and Submit.
And that's it.
Just like that I'm done with
my purchase from Overstock.
My soccer ball's on its way.
They showed that I paid with
my Google Wallet account,
so I didn't have to go in and
type in a credit card number
or any of that, type
in my shipping address.
OK.
So there were a few
things we saw there.
And I want to go back through
them a little slower now.
As you see, we can
go through check
out very quickly
using Google Wallet.
But let's take things
a little bit slower.
The first step in
integration and in that flow
there was requesting was
called a Masked Wallet.
That might sound
kind of mysterious,
but it's really just your
wallet information, your payment
information, and an address.
We call it masked because
we only share the last four
digits of your
credit card number.
So we just tell
Overstock, hey, they're
going to pay with
Visa ending in 1234.
And we give Overstock,
in this case,
your shipping address,
since they probably
need that to calculate
shipping cost or taxes.
So that's the first step is
getting that masked wallet
from Google.
The next step is displaying
that information.
So when we saw the Checkout
screen on Overstock,
they showed that same
masked wallet information.
So the user sees it.
The user knows, OK, yeah, this
is going to the right address.
And this is charging
the right credit card.
Once you get a chance
to review that,
then you can submit the order.
And that's when
Overstock asked us
for what we call a Full Wallet.
A Full Wallet is where we
generate a one-time card
that we then give to Overstock,
plus, again, the shipping
address, since that's
an important part
of the transaction.
That credit card is just a
normal credit card number,
just like a number that a user
would have typed in themselves.
There is no difference with it.
So they can just take that, send
it to their back end systems,
to their order
management systems,
send it to their
payment processor,
just like they would with
any other credit card,
and then start the
order management flow.
Now this flow hasn't changed
really at all from a year ago
when we launched the product.
But from our launch
partners we get
a lot of really useful feedback.
And one of things we realized
was the first two steps here,
the Masked Wallet and
Display Mask Wallet
steps, a lot of times those are
really, really similar for each
of our partners
who've integrated.
It's not always the same for
everybody, but in many cases
it is.
And so we thought, is there a
way that we can learn from this
and make it even
easier for folks?
And that's where we got the
idea for the Wallet Fragment.
The Wallet Fragment
has a couple of modes.
If you go back to the Overstock
app, in that Cart page,
do you see that Buy
with Google button?
That's the Wallet Fragment.
That's the Wallet Fragment
in the Button Mode.
And so it's just displaying
that Buy with Google button.
There's a couple
options you have
there for changing the text.
You can do a Buy Now if
you like, for example.
And the button is
very, very re-sizable.
It will very dynamically
fit into whatever space
you tell it to fit into.
And it's just like a
normal view in Android
that you can give it all the
different kinds of layout
parameters you're used to.
You don't have to learn any
kind of new special syntax
to get this to fit into
your UI very nicely.
So the button displays there.
And it handles all its own taps.
So when I tapped
on it, Overstock
didn't have to write any
code to handle my tap.
The button itself
handled the tap.
The Wallet Fragment
That brought up the Wallet UI.
And then at the
end of that flow,
we returned a Masked
Wallet to Overstock.
We returned that Masked Wallet
via the "on activity result"
call back, just like
our existing APIs.
So no change there.
We still returned the
data to the applications
in the same way.
The next screen we saw was the
checkout page on Overstock.
Now take a look at the
top part of that screen.
You see the payment method,
the Google Wallet, the shipping
address, and the Change
buttons over there.
That's the Wallet
Fragment again.
But this time, it's
in the Details mode.
Now the rest of the screen--
the action bar, the item
information, the total
tax, Submit button,
all those things, that's
just the Overstock app there.
All they've done is drop in
our fragment on the screen.
But you couldn't really
tell that these are actually
coming from two
different processes.
That's because we allow a lot
of customization of the Wallet
Fragment, especially
in Details mode.
You can customize the background
colors, the text colors,
text sizes, the button colors.
You can provide
your own drawables.
We wanted to make it where
this could fit in seamlessly
to the existing application,
so that it looked
like it was built by Overstock.
But actually, this
was built by Google.
All this UI is being created
separately and injected
into the Overstock application.
Once again, you have the
Change buttons there.
And any taps of
those buttons are
handled by the Wallet
Fragment itself.
So if the user wanted
to change it and say,
actually, oh, let me change
what shipping address
to send this to, then,
once again, a new Masked
Wallet would be created and
returned to the Overstock
application via "on
activity result."
So if they had to
then recalculate
shipping costs or sales tax,
they could do that, of course.
So Wallet Fragment
addresses one issue of, here
are these common things we
see in these applications,
can we make it easier?
But just how much
easier could we make it?
So let's take a look at the
code for using Wallet Fragment.
There's just three
steps to using it.
First, is you create a fragment.
We have a nice little
Builder method for it.
And you have to tell it
what mode to put it in.
We saw the Button mode.
We saw the Details mode.
So you just tell it here
what mode to put it in.
Next, you initialize it.
And this is where you give a
Masked Wallet request to it.
The Masked Wallet request is
how you specify things like,
hey, I need a shipping address,
or maybe I need a phone number,
or I don't need a phone
number, or maybe I
don't need a shipping
address at all.
That's where you specify
those types of things,
so we know what
kind of data to make
sure to return to
your application.
So you initialize the Fragment
with that request information.
And then this is just
an Android fragment.
So the way you add it
to your application
is just like you would any other
fragment, in this case, using
a fragment to transaction.
You can actually reference
the Wallet Fragment via XML
as well, if you like to use
XML to do all your layouts.
Either option works.
It's just like a
normal fragment.
So you just drop it
into your application
just like any other
fragment you would do.
And that's it.
So we think this is pretty easy.
We think you can really
eliminate a lot of code.
In fact, we integrated a Wallet
Fragment into our sample code.
So if you go to the Google
Play services client
library and the
SDK add-on, you'll
see the sample
application for Wallet.
And if you get it
today, you'll have
a version that uses
Wallet Fragment.
Now some of you may recognize
the screen shot here.
Many folks here use the
Gerrit code review tool.
If you do any
Android development,
it's the defacto way
you do code reviews.
So this was the change where we
dropped in the Wallet Fragment
and removed the previous code.
Altogether, we got rid
of 800 lines of code
from our sample
application by switching
to using the Wallet Fragment.
Now if you're a new
developer, new to Wallet,
you won't even want to
bother with the old way.
Just go straight to using
the Wallet Fragment.
If you used it on an
existing integration then
you can really eliminate
a lot of code like we did.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: 1,100
lines of code, Michael?
I'm just a Product Manager.
I didn't realize developers
write that much code just
for a button.
MICHAEL GALPIN: Yeah,
it actually is true.
When we're not watching
World Cup games,
we do write a lot of code.
But with Wallet Fragment,
you can write less code.
OK.
So Wallet Fragment
makes it even easier
to integrate Instant Buy.
But again, it
wouldn't even matter
if Instant Buy wasn't
a compelling product.
As Prakash went over some
of these points earlier,
the reasons you want
to use Instant Buy.
The top two here--
faster checkout,
don't make people type
in credit card numbers.
Use the credit cards
they've already got.
Skip registration and sign-in.
Don't make someone
have to remember
some other crazy password
that they're probably
going to forget or just going
to use the same password they've
used everywhere else and create
some more security problems.
Just use Google
Sign-In for that.
It's more secure.
It's secure for the users.
They are able to protect
their information.
They don't share their
full credit card numbers.
It's more secure for you guys.
Google's risk engine is
always looking out for fraud,
always protecting
the transactions.
And then you saw how lightweight
the integration can be.
I just showed you the
Wallet Fragment part
which made it even easier.
But as Prakash
mentioned earlier,
most developers are able
to do all the integration
in about a week.
We try to keep it super light.
On Android, we're part
of Google Play services.
So if you get the Play
Services client library,
just compile it into your code.
You may already have the
Play Services Client Library,
if you're using things like
Sign-In, or Maps, or Google+.
Any of those things, it's
the same client library.
And finally, no additional
fees, of course.
We're just giving
you the credit card
that you're using, just like
you would any other credit card.
So you send it to your
payment processor.
So there's nothing
extra happening here.
No extra fees from Google.
So we talked
earlier about how we
want to go not just in
payments, but really Wallet
is going beyond
payments into commerce.
So I'm going to hand
it back over to Prakash
to talk about how
we're doing that.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Great.
Thank you, Michael.
So just for some
context, last year at I/O
we introduced something
called Wallet Objects.
So essentially, it's
the notion of digitizing
your entire physical wallet,
not just your payment cards,
but your loyalty
cards, your offers,
and putting it into
the Google Cloud
and accessing it
from any device.
So I personally get inundated
with emails, with offers.
I sign up for loyalty programs.
I forget what I signed up for.
And then when I
actually need to use it,
I don't have a contextual
way to retrieve it.
So that's the problem
we are solving.
We are freeing your
customers from having
to carry these physical cards
for loyalty, these printed
offers.
When they want to redeem a
coupon, all they have to do
is save to Google on your
mobile app or your site,
and they're done.
But there's more
to it than that.
So the other thing is
branding and reach.
If you have a loyalty card
that you put to save to Google
you get [INAUDIBLE]
in the Google Wallet.
And I'm going to show you
a demo of how this works.
So you get more
distribution and branding.
The third thing I
want to talk about
is engagement and
also redemption.
So I'll give you an example.
I have a Walgreens loyalty card.
When I go in a Walgreens
store, I get notified.
So I have my balance
rewards number.
I don't need to carry
my physical card.
And if I have an offer, I
can actually redeem it there.
So it's what I call
smart notifications.
I don't get notified if I
am driving by or walking by.
I get it when I'm in the
store, so it's not spam.
And what helps you
as a developer is,
through these contextual
notifications,
it drives engagement.
And I'm more likely
to redeem that offer.
I'm more likely to
use that loyalty card,
if it's in the palm of my hand.
So let me give an example.
And we're going to actually
use a real partner app.
So first, just for context,
this is the Google Wallet app.
So as you can see, I don't have
any offers saved right now.
If I had any offers
saved to Google,
you would have seen them here.
And now what I'm going to
do is go to the Belly app.
So Belly is one of
my favorite apps.
I love offers.
And like I mentioned
earlier, I'm still hungry.
So continuing with
that theme, let
me save this jerk
chicken wrap offer.
As you can see,
it's very simple.
I save it to Google.
And like I said
earlier, when you
do that, it's
saved to the cloud.
And I can access it any time.
But don't take my word for it.
So let's go back.
And as you can see, the
offer showed up right here.
So now when I'm
walking past 876 Cafe,
I'll get a geonotification
saying, here's this offer.
Do you want to use it?
And I can use it.
I can save money as a consumer.
And it can drive engagement for
you as a developer or brand.
So this is, again,
going back to commerce
is more than just payments.
And we are trying to
cover that entire life
cycle of a consumer's journey.
So just in terms of
other housekeeping notes,
I'd also like to--
before we wrap up--
just do a few pointers.
One is-- I mentioned earlier, we
have sandbox open to everybody.
So I'd encourage you to
go to our developer site.
It's
developers.google.com/wallet.
We have an interest
form if you want
to sign up for Instant Buy.
We have also an
interest form if you
want to sign up
for Wallet Objects.
And the other thing
is if you want
to talk to us in person we
have an office hour session
today at 1:00 PM.
So I'd encourage you
all to come by if you'd
like to have a further detailed
discussion on anything we
talked about today.
MICHAEL GALPIN: And
just to reiterate
one thing on the sign-ups.
For Instant Buy, you can
install the Play Services client
library and start developing
against our sandbox
immediately.
There's nothing to sign up for.
You could do it right
now from your laptop,
if you had it with you.
There is an interest form to
fill out for production access.
The Save to Google APIs, they're
in a beta phase right now.
So you need to fill out
an interest form with us,
and then we'll give you
access to those APIs as well.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: OK.
Great.
So we'd like to keep the
floor open for questions now.
We'd love to hear from you
about any questions you have,
especially on the
challenges you might
be having with monetization.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I'm actually
just curious to know
how Google actually
makes money from this.
Are you not getting any
fees from the partners?
And then just a second question.
Just philosophically,
how has Google
thought about payments
changing over time
in terms of where you
were five years ago
and what Google
Instant Pay is today?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Sure.
That's a great question.
So I think, as I said earlier,
this is a free product.
So we are really focused
on the consumer experience.
What we would like to
do, I mentioned earlier,
we are in a mobile-first world.
And we really believe there
is a big problem that has not
been tackled, which is the
mobile shopping experience.
So what we'd like to do
is improve that shopping
experience by reducing
friction, driving conversion,
because that's something that
our consumers are asking for.
That's something our retailers
and advertisers are asking for.
So that's our main driver
behind being in the space.
In terms of how we see payments
evolving, like I said earlier,
I gave you more than
a hint about that.
I said, we're looking
at the whole commerce
journey, the whole
shopping journey.
And what we are trying to
do is help the consumer
along every point
in that journey.
And to us, payments
is one element of it.
The other element where we
think we can bring value
is things we are demonstrating
in the partner showcase.
So for example, I mentioned
earlier Hotel Tonight,
not only can you use
two-click checkout,
you can actually
use Google assets,
Google APIs to
get keyless entry.
With JackThreads, not only can
you use two-click checkout,
you can actually have
a virtual hang out,
try something on
from your living room
before you actually
buy it online.
With Eat24, you can be watching
your favorite football game
on Android TV and
order it from there.
So that's the future we
see where you actually
make it a delightful commerce
experience for the user
and put not just payments,
but the other Google
assets as part of their journey.
Go ahead, please.
AUDIENCE: You guys talked
a lot about physical goods,
but a lot of the
people you listed
are obviously services and/or
digital goods potentially.
In light of that,
can you guys talk
about how the-- since you're on
IO-- Android and iOS Play Store
policies come into
play, and when
you can use Wallet versus
when you have to use
Play store for different
aspects of purchasing?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So when we said
physical goods, we
meant physical
goods and services.
If you have digital goods
we have a great API,
Google Wallet In-app Billing.
So we'd encourage
you to use that.
And the other thing is these
are two very different things,
that Google Wallet In-app
Billing is a solution that also
processes your
payment, provides you
distribution, and many other
things that you can read up
on our website.
What we're offering
is specifically
designed for physical goods.
We do not process your payment.
So anything that you have
that's a digital good consumed
on or off the device should
use the In-App Billing API.
Anything like purchasing a
ticket or a physical good
would be the Google
Wallet Instant Buy API.
And if you want, I'm happy to
chat with you after the session
and walk through in more detail.
MICHAEL GALPIN: And just
to add one thing to that,
the Play In-app Billing does a
lot of awesome things for you
in terms of keeping track of
what items has a user purchased
and all that.
So it's a very, very rich API.
Whereas, this is very
much focused just
on facilitating payments.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So if you already have
a pre-optimized flow for return
customers on your
website or app,
is it possible to have the first
visit go through this system,
and then the return visit just
go through your regular system?
Can you reuse that
information a second time,
or a third time,
or a fourth time?
MICHAEL GALPIN: So one
key aspect to Instant Buy
is that we are generating
a one-time card.
So that card's not meant to
be reused over and over again.
That's part of the security
that we provide to users
that, if that card was
somehow compromised,
the risk there to
them is very limited.
But otherwise, yes, I think
what you're talking about
would definitely possible.
But just keep in mind
that you can't just
reuse that same
card that you used
last time from Instant Buy.
AUDIENCE: So is there a way to
get a new card without showing
the user the whole flow,
like if they want to say,
I want this again.
Or do you have to send them
all the way back through
and have them pick an
address and a credit card
and everything?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
I think a lot depends
on how your flow works exactly.
But we do think it's very
important that people
see what card's getting
charged for them.
So we do think it's important
to display that information
and give them a way to change it
in case like, oh, I don't want
to use that card anymore
or the shipping address.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I assume you could
still show the last four
digits, the ones that
are shown in the--
MICHAEL GALPIN: So, yeah.
I failed to mention earlier when
I went through the Overstock
demo, but you might have noticed
there was a check box saying,
use Wallet as my
default in the future.
If you leave that checked,
then in the future,
you skip the Wallet UI part.
But we still ask that you show
that information to the user.
We think that's a good user
experience for them to see that
and to know what's
getting charged.
AUDIENCE: I have one more
question, but he can go next.
AUDIENCE: Oh, thank you.
Is there an option
for revenue sharing?
Because in Paypal, for
instance, I develop a site,
and I get a cut of the payment.
And it's just automatic.
I don't have to do anything.
So is there an option in Google
Wallet for revenue sharing?
I've asked the
question last year too.
And the person said, yeah,
yeah, we're looking at that.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
So I think, first,
just to reiterate
what we said earlier,
we don't process your payment.
So Paypal processes
your payment.
The way our model
works is whoever
you're using for processing,
like Braintree, or Stripe,
or Paymentech, you'll
continue using that.
And we don't charge any fees.
So that's one fundamental
distinction we have.
Again, I don't have the
specifics of this revenue
sharing thing that you have.
MICHAEL GALPIN: We don't
take any of your revenue.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I see.
But there is a Google
Wall-- some kind of-- when
you say in-app, there's an
in-app web version, not only
Play Store.
I know I used it.
Right?
Is there a different
group then that does--
MICHAEL GALPIN: That's a
different product for the web.
And that does have a revenue
share associated to it.
AUDIENCE: So there is a
revenue share for that one?
I'll talk to you afterwards.
MICHAEL GALPIN: Yeah.
Please come by the office hours.
We can go into that.
Absolutely.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
How many of the total users,
for Android specifically,
actually has a Wallet
account percentage-wise?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So we
don't disclose those numbers.
You probably saw the
presentation yesterday
on the growth of Android.
And you saw the show of
hands earlier when I said,
how many of you have
made a purchase on Play
or any other property on Google?
So essentially, anyone who's
made a purchase on Play
has set up a Google
Wallet account.
AUDIENCE: Percentage-wise,
do you know how much is that?
30%?
90%?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: So we
don't share those numbers.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Because that's part of the
[INAUDIBLE] eventually.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Right.
AUDIENCE: If this
doesn't have a Wallet.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: I agree.
Great question.
So the best way I
can answer it is
with public information
in our case studies.
So I talked earlier about Eat24.
One of every three
transactions on Android
after they implemented
is with Google Wallet.
I talked about the
other four case studies,
too, where they had a
similar share of Wallet.
So I would say that's probably
your best signal in terms
of attraction we have
with Google Wallet.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And by the way, if I don't
have a Wallet account,
does the Checkout button
become a Register button?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI:
Great question.
So if you click on
Buy With Google--
so when Michael showed the demo
on Overstock-- if you don't
have a Wallet
account, it's going
to guide you to
the Setup screen.
But even there,
thanks to Michael,
we have been able
to reduce friction.
So what I mean by that is we
use our Places Autocomplete API,
so you don't have to
enter your full address.
We have OCR, so you
can actually take
a picture of your credit card.
We didn't show a
demo of the setup,
but we have tried to even make
that as painless as possible
in Google Wallet.
MICHAEL GALPIN: And once
you set up there, then you
can use that same Wallet account
on all the Google properties,
including in Play.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was
just wondering how
this works outside of the
credit card ecosystem.
So if you're dealing
internationally,
for instance, in where I come
from in the Netherlands, 70%,
80% of all transactions
are with online banking.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: OK.
Great question.
So today, this is
a US-only product.
That's all I can say.
One thing I didn't
mention earlier
is we take your
feedback to heart.
So a lot of the features
we have this year
were based on feedback
we've gotten in the past.
So all I can say is, yes,
we hear you loud and clear.
And stay tuned.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: For the
Coupon and Loyalty
Card Program buttons, is that
only for brick and mortar
retail?
Or does it work for
websites and things, too?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: You can
use it for websites, too.
But one of the things
I talked earlier about
was driving engagement
and redemption.
So we found it resonates most
with an in-store4 component
because, when we talked
to our developers,
they said, I want to get
somebody in my store.
I want it to be very contextual.
You could use it for, like
I said, more than that.
But we found most of the
attraction and interest
we have is for our
retailers who actually
have an in-store component.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MICHAEL GALPIN: Yeah, like when
you create one of those offers,
you can put geofence locations
for your stores, for example.
So then, as Prakash
mentioned, users
get walking through your
store, they get notified.
Hey, I've got this offer to you.
So we definitely found a lot of
value for physical locations.
But it does work
for digital as well.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I have a
quick question for you.
Everything you've talked about
today has been around mobile.
And I just want to
confirm a statement
that I thought I heard you say
early on in the presentation.
This is available also
on desktop, correct?
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Yes.
So we are available across
all of major platforms
everywhere, Android, iOS,
mobile web, and desktop.
And we actually do
have partners who
have done that integration
across all platforms, Orbitz,
Fancy, which I talked about.
We have more than
a dozen developers
who have actually gotten
value not just on mobile,
but across the entire
platform spectrum.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great.
Thanks.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm from Overstock, so we
were part of that integration.
This is more of a plug
feedback kind of a thing.
There's a 67% conversion, once
they do buy with Google Wallet.
So we're really excited
about the conversion rate.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Thank you.
Thank you.
MICHAEL GALPIN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And we're really
happy with that integration.
I guess the one feedback
I would like to provide
is maybe if you could
raise the dollar
amount that you guys
support on the back end.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Sure.
That's a great
piece of feedback.
So one thing is, with
the one-time card,
we have a limit of
$2,000 per transaction.
So we are looking
at various things.
And generally, we have
found that, for the majority
of our customers, it
fits into their 95
percentile of transaction size.
But that's great feedback.
Thank you.
MICHAEL GALPIN: We
limit things, again,
as security for our customers,
for Google Wallet users.
So that way, again, if there
is any kind of compromise,
the amount of damage that
can be done is very limited.
But we certainly understand
there are apps out there
where the transaction
amounts can be greater
than that amount.
So we hear you.
PRAKASH HARIRAMANI: Great.
So unless there's any
other questions-- so again,
we'll be there at office
hours, 1:00 PM in the pod.
So we look forward to
seeing many of you there.
And thank you,
again, for coming.
[APPLAUSE]